So, here it is.
It's because of
verses like this that the early
Christians expanded on this notion
and came up with stories
going in greater detail than what we
have here.
In fact, I'm going to kill three birds
with one stone.
Do you know the Quran says that the
reason why
Satan fell?
You know the Quran says that the reason
why Satan fell
is because Allah commanded the angels
to bow down and worship of Adam.
All the angels did except Iblis, who
supposedly said he was a jinn.
And why? Well, here, let me show you.
Let Let me bring up an article I wrote.
Because Iblis says, "I'm better than
him. You made me from smokeless fire.
You made him from mud, from clay.
Right?
Do you know that story is not a
concoction of Muhammad?
Muhammad didn't make up that story.
Muhammad, being an ear,
heard
the story
circulating among Jews and Christians
cuz this is actually a Jewish and
Christian story.
That when God created Adam,
he told Michael to summon angels
and command them, "Worship the image of
God." And Michael was the first, but
Satan said, "I refuse. Why? I'm better
than him."
It is even found in a work called The
Life of Adam and Eve.
So, this story in the Quran, Muhammad
didn't make up. He's an ear. He heard
the story and parroted it. But, what are
the details? And I have an article on
that. Let me get it to you.
So, what does this tell you? That the
Christians,
in order to
elaborate on
what verses like Wisdom chapter 2 state,
assumed
that the reason why the devil became
envious is because when God made man the
height of his creation
and angels subservient to man,
not only was Satan envious,
but the envy was due to the fact that
God even commanded the angels commanded
the angels to worship Adam because he
was the image bearer of God. Let me find
it for you.
And then
and Eve. Let me see.
I have an article, but I don't know what
the name of the article is. I'll find it
for you, I promise you.
Here we go. This is one of them right
here.
There you go, right here. You right You
ready? Here it is.
Where did Muhammad get this story from?
There you go. Thank you, Jeremy. He's
already clipped it.
Yep, that's why he was called an ear cuz
he loved to plagiarize.
All right.
There you go, right here.
Let's read it. Life of Adam and Eve,
Vitae
Adae et Evae, the Apocrypha and
Pseudepigrapha, volume 2, page 137. It's
also online. I have an online link for
the online version.
You ready? Let's read it.
Let's start right here.
Here you go.
We'll start. I quote several sources.
Let's read this one first.
When thou was formed,
this is Satan speaking.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> I was hurled out of the presence of God
and banished from the company of the
angels. Why? When God blew into thee the
breath of life and thy face and likeness
were made in the image of God, Michael
also brought thee and made us worship
thee
in the sight of God and God the Lord
spake, "Here is Adam.
I have made thee
in our [clears throat] image and
likeness." Michael went out and called
the angels saying, "Worship the image of
God as the Lord God hath commanded."
Michael kept urging me to worship. Then
he called me and said, "Worship the
image of God the Lord."
And I answered,
>> [clears throat]
>> "I have no need to worship Adam.
And since Michael kept urging me to
worship, I said to him, "Why does thou
urge me?
I will not worship an inferior
and younger being than I.
I am a senior in the creation.
Before he was made, was I already made.
It is his duty to worship me. That's the
envy.
That's the envy. You see it?
You guys learning a lot and being
reminded of a lot that I've covered over
the years?
When the angels were under me
heard this, they refused to worship him.
And Michael said, "Worship the image of
God." Again, we're warning them.
"But if thou will not worship him, the
Lord God will be wrath with thee."
And I said, "If he be wrath with me, I
will set my seat above the stars of
heaven and will be like the highest."
Now,
two things I want you to note.
On the basis of passages such as Wisdom
chapter 2:24,
where
due to the devil's envy,
he brought death unto mankind, meaning
there's a direct connection. His envy
and jealousy of man is what moved them
to cause man
to die by sinning against God.
Number one,
they elaborated
the fact
of
the devil being envious of Adam.
They correctly realized that man is the
crown of God's creation
given dominion over all the other
creatures including angels. That's in
the Bible. I'll show you the verses.
And that made the devil envious.
Oh, there goes my daughter again. Hold
on.
Okay.
Here you go.
From this story, you see
what would lead Christians to elaborate
on the nature
of the devil's envy. He was obviously
envious of man, but why?
The Bible tells you. Man was made
the crown of God's creation.
Everything was put under the dominion of
man. Man being subject only to God. And
I'll give you the song which says this.
All right.
But notice what else they quoted.
Does this passage sound familiar?
I will set my seat above the stars of
heaven. And I'll be the highest. That's
Isaiah 14
12 to 15.
Did you catch it?
So, here you have early sources
Jewish and Christian sources
interpreting Isaiah 14
about Satan.
Here it is.
Okay, let's see what this is quoting
from.
Isaiah 14 verse 14. We'll go to 15.
There you go.
How
you are fallen from heaven.
How you are cut down to the ground, you
who laid the nations low. You said in
your heart, I will ascend to heaven
above the stars of God. I will set my
throne on high.
I will sit on the mount of assembly in
the far north. I will ascend above the
heights of the clouds. I will make
myself like the most high.
Isaiah 14:14.
Quoted
by this early
non-canonical source, The Life of Adam
and Eve,
preserved
by Christians.
And that tells you
in the early centuries, Christians were
already seeing
a reference to Satan in Isaiah 14.
Right?
Okay.
Now, let's go back to the article. Now,
everyone got that, right? We saw that.
All right. So, now that's one source.
Here's another one.
I quote another.
This is from the Book of the Cave of
Treasures.
Now, the Book of the Cave of Treasures
is an Ethiopian work.
If I
I'm not mistaken, my memory doesn't fail
me,
this is actually
a book highly cherished and prized by
the Coptic Church, the Book of the Cave
of Treasures.
Look what it says.
Right?
Yep, I was right, Coptic text, you see.
Yep, it's been a while. I don't read my
articles, guys.
So, let me see where this is from.
Yep.
Coptic source. Let me read that, then
we're going to read this.
E. A. Wallis Budge, Miscellaneous Coptic
Texts.
Published by Oxford 1915, pages 904 and
906, okay?
But here,
the Book of the Cave of Treasures,
Budge published it or wrote it,
published in
London, 1917, page 55. Look, and when
the prince of the lower
order of angels saw
what great majesty had been given Adam,
he was jealous of him from that day, and
he did not wish to worship him. And he
said unto his host, "You shall not
worship him.
You shall not praise him with the
angels. It is meet that you worship me,
because I'm fire and spirit. This is
where Muhammad is getting these stories
from.
And not that I should worship a thing of
dust,
which has been fashioned a fine dust.
And the rebel meditating
the rebel meditating
these things
would not render obedience to God, and
of his own free will, he asserted his
independence, separated himself from
God, but he was swept away out of heaven
and fell.
How about this one?
This is from whom?
Coptics, this is one of your
archbishops.
In the Iconium of Theo Theo
Theodosius,
archbishop of Alexandria in the year 567
AD. You see where Muhammad is getting
these stories from?
Right?
And I got this from Wilson B. Bishai's
article, "A Possible Coptic Source for a
Chronic Text."
Reproduced in Ibn Warraq's What the
Quran Really Says, published by
Prometheus Books,
part 4 5B, pages 288 to 295.
All right?
Okay?
What does it say? Adam says, "He
breathed into my face a breath of life."
Okay?
Here we go.
And he commanded all the hosts of
heaven, who were in truth under his
power, saying, "Come ye and worship the
work of my hands, my likeness, my image.
And there was there a hateful being
who was of the earlier creation, that is
to say, Satanael,
Satana el.
Adversary of God.
El is God. Satanael
who is called the devil, and he was an
archangel. Furthermore,
when the command had issued from the
mouth of God, Michael the archangel and
his host came and they bowed low in
homage even as in Adam.
I did not Michael, I'm sorry.
And so likewise and all the host of
angels, each rank in its proper order.
Finally, the master said unto Mastema,
the interpretation of which is hater,
hater,
always hating.
Come now also and worship the work of my
hands. Satanael answered boldly said,
"Far be it from thee to make me worship
this thing of the earth."
Damn Gina.
It's all about you.
Okay?
Now watch here.
But I said to God said unto him,
"Satanael, hearken unto me."
And the Mastema said, "Far be it from us
to worship that which is inferior to us.
Moreover, we are beings of spirit, but
this creature is of the earth."
Straightaway, immediately,
God was angry and he commanded a mighty
cherubim
who smote him, reduced him to
helplessness, and he cast him and those
who were with him forth from heaven. And
the good God cried unto Michael, "I know
that the Mastema will fight against my
created being wishing to cast him away
from me even as I cast Mastema forth
from my kingdom. But behold, I entrust
my created beings unto thee."
To the protection of Michael.
Okay.
Do you guys understand the point?
Satana. Yeah, we say too my language
Satana.
It's my language, too.
On the basis of wisdom chapter 2:24,
we now see
the devil
condemned himself out of envy and
jealousy for man.
There we have it.
Satan was jealous
about man's status. He could not accept
and allow someone later in time
created of the dust of the earth could
be ranked
ahead of him, above him.
His ego would not allow it.
And because of that, he became cursed.
In other words, you are the reason and
the cause of the devil's condemnation.
And because of that, he comes after you.